this is Millard Fillmore he's known for
looking exactly like Alec Baldwin hiya
Mars hi I'm Patrick hi I'm Matt hello I
am a he's and today we're identifying us
I think I'm gonna do okay I wrote a book
called the presidential book where you
put stickers on the presidents of the
United States and also listed all their
moves and so I I knew a lot of them
really well there's a couple of beardy
looking guys that I'm worried about they
all look the same but I think I'll be
alright I am also very confident I had
to memorize these in fourth grade and
since then I've read a biography of
every single one of these men I took AP
US history in high school so mr. father
if you're out there I'm about to either
make you proud or embarrass you I've
just like watched a film let's get
started
okay how should we do this do you want
to like try to go in order yeah let's
try to go in order and then we'll do it
once an order and then look we'll fill
in the blanks okay yeah well alright
does I got Washington here well that's
not order but okay wait where we gonna
go backwards Oh Lincoln alright let's
communicate alright I'll start on this
side you want to handle that side and
then we'll meet in the middle
sounds good okay okay that's a general
this is grant this is Abraham Lincoln
this is Clinton this is a bearded man
Hayes Jesus we know who is carrying the
weight and there's Richard Nixon all
right not a creek well you know he's
definitely a crook 100% this one first
guy to be impeached George Bush Senior I
love your quiz and give me the first
letter of his last name
Jay Johnson yes Taft the guy that
supposed to got stuck in a bathtub but
actually didn't guys fun fact that's a
lie he was just big cartoon cat Garfield
I like this this is fun this is grant
is that task
no no this is Millard Fillmore he's
known for looking exactly like Alec
Baldwin this is he was president after
he got shot he got shot yeah
Wow a lot of presidents does that first
letter of his last name a second letter
this is warren g harding harding of
memory serves died of eating bad crab so
that can happen to you
just tell me Arthur Chester Chester this
is Calvin Coolidge he didn't say much so
we're not gonna say much about him
oh [ __ ] I'm gonna let you start right
okay this is George Bush
this is Eisenhower he city in Ohio
Cleveland yes Grover Cleveland yes this
is uh Woodrow Wilson oh okay is that
Millard Fillmore no this is one of the
very looking guys and I'm gonna wait on
I think it's Hayes but we're gonna wait
this is george w bush
this is Trump though I wish it was
Hillary got a hurry up Benjamin Harrison
this is harry s truman the s just stands
for s there's no actual initial there
also he dropped the bomb less of a fun
fact that's Teddy yes this is JFK this
is george bush george w bush this is
Herbert Hoover he started that he had
start the depression but he didn't make
it better
Millard Fillmore you're gonna get it to
an eventual I know I can't wait
yeah oh this is Reagan and I feel really
lucky that I got paired with a historian
apparently this is LBJ Obama John Adam
mm-hmm this is Franklin Pierce I think
he was drunk a lot unfortunately this
his wife died it's kind of a bummer
actually you know what cut that it's a
bar Addison Monroe actually don't think
that's James Madison cuz this isn't
James Madison the fourth president he's
kind of chunky no he's a skinny tiny man
these aren't the pictures that I saw in
Wikipedia this Henry that I think is
John Tyler oh yeah you're right I think
it's John no it is that John Tyler I
think that might be Harrison but that's
a weird-looking picture so I want to
wait until we go through the others come
you know let's let's let's come back
okay ooh Andrew Jackson yes hello this
guy Van Buren
that's Van Buren yeah that is Van Buren
I think he was at Hamilton Andrew
Johnson yeah
Millard Fillmore that's Jim's gay pole
cousins Ford that's Ford Jefferson uh
McKinley that might be McCann I'm gonna
wait on that
that's FDR this is Buchanan right the
hat looks like mccannon yes no no that's
either that's the other Madison or
Monroe this is Jefferson all right so we
think this is this is Madison and this
is Monroe who this is Andrew Jackson he
was roundly a jerk Millard Fillmore
watch this be Millard Fillmore Adams jr.
yes John Quincy Adams yes oh [ __ ] okay
Oh God Van Buren this is Chester a
Arthur really just option with golden
president mutton chops
this is Harding okay let's do the beardy
guy yeah I think this is Garfield Bay
Clinton that is Cleveland this is Taft
FDR fun fact we share the same birthday
May 29th okay I'm gonna say I'm gonna
say that too and then let's go ahead and
say that's Benjamin Harrison oh my god
I'm gonna out of Reagan Reaganomics
Truman FDA Hey
okay oh we're doing pretty good my
handwriting is atrocious I'm worried
about who this is this Harrison he died
right well I know I think about Terrace
and I think that's Tyler as William
Henry Harrison so W Harrison is this
Sherman nope he replaced Nixon bored
yes I think it's McKinley McKinley is my
best I'm gonna go with your gut feeling
cuz okay you've clearly like gotten this
entire side down we already do Millard
Fillmore that's us Joan Adams for sure
yes man anyone a poem there's Washington
we got this far it didn't do Washington
amazing George yes this is John Tyler
that's McKinley Madison has a widow's
peak four days that's his deal and
Monroe looks different in every picture
I've ever seen of him so that has to be
mine let's do it
that's do you Canon Imus John Tyler
where is the other where's the guy that
you should know that's John Tyler
battered Ella I'm in Zachary Taylor
sorry oh yeah no that's Taylor
eisenhower have you got Zachary I figure
eight okay go for it
Zachary Taylor ah go away from McKinley
we have it set him you know more yeah
all right so we sure that this is Monroe
and this is Madison I think we did it
yes these aren't the pictures I saw in
Wikipedia so let's switch him okay I
know Garfield is balding I think Hayes
had the longest beard and Harrison
looked like the average of the two is
how I tried to remember this yeah yeah
we don't need it I mean I could do some
stand-up we got a wall we got a home one
two three let's look okay damn it I
would not have brought me Alec Baldwin
thing I didn't know the and I will never
forget it now
viewers at home there's a thing called a
Freudian slip and that is what happened
but this I am disappointed in myself and
I am sorry to the Kennedys I feel like
we empirically killed it like I so I
think we did all right I think we
crushed the other team yeah apparently
mr. father he did me good
Pierce he's a little Millard Fillmore
but he can get it
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]